[Music]
I am here with Scott Snyder one of my
favorite comic book writers working
today I am obsessed with your Batman I'm
so excited to see you team up with
cupolo again what has it been like
working with him to get you guys have a
great like shorthand
oh yeah he's like family to me at this
point I mean we never really stopped
talking so even though we haven't been
doing a book together for a while you
know we text and call and all of it like
pretty much every day
so to me it hasn't it hasn't been a
break because we've been talking about
the ideas for this book for years if we
really came up with this one Batman last
night on earth when we were doing 0 year
it was actually at this con when I was
starting Batman and I was freaking out
because I was so just terrified of the
book I bumped into Grant Morrison and
Grant Morrison said to me you know I
won't try to do his accent it always
comes out sounding like some bad Boston
accent or whatever but he's like um you
know how you're gonna get over your
jitters you've got to give your Batman
at birth and a death
give him your version of the origin
story and give him your Dark Knight
Returns and so I started thinking about
this when I began thinking about zero
year I thought it was amazing advice
from him he always has incredible advice
but so this story has been in my head
for about I guess five years you know
six years so it really is the
culmination of everything we've built on
Batman
you know every aspect of it is is some
kind of return to home everything about
it is about everything about it really
centers on this notion of a world that
doesn't want it superheroes anymore that
has chosen the villains and what is
Batman's place in that world it's a lot
of money literally like you know I I
remember pitching it to Greg and I was
telling him it opens book one opens with
Bruce on a case when he's in the middle
of trying to solve this case and
suddenly he wakes up in Arkham Asylum
and his doctor is there and his doctor
looks oddly like the Joker and he's
saying thank God we finally found a
medicine that breaks through to you you
know you've been here for ten years ever
since you killed your parents in that
alley Bruce yeah and he looks around and
his chiropractor looks a lot like Bane
and every you know he's so and as he
starts to discover this is all just a
big cage built for him and sets out on
this Odyssey I think you'll see a very
very change DC Universe the big moment
for me was when Alfred felt like he
betrayed him and you're not sure if you
should trust it because Alfred's choice
makes you question everything even more
exactly because if Alfred's that sense
of right and wrong
so if Alfred's making a choice you're
like Bruce what have you done which i
think is a great use of that character
cuz he's such a strong character oh I
love Alfred as a dad alfred is one of my
favorites to write and one of my least
favorites cuz he always gets hurt you
know it's like he's the father who has a
son who does something that's he loves
and admires and and you know but puts
his son in the line of danger a lot and
I just I feel that with my kids when I
see them do anything dangerous that I'm
still proud of them for doing you know
yeah anything ambitious so yeah Alfred
Alfred is close to my heart he's a
perfect redshirt he's always yeah sure
and that's the problem yes so if last
night on earth represents the end of
this tale where would the Batman who
laughs lies that like a side street yeah
well I guess what I'd say is for me I
think the the way I would sell my work
to everybody out there beyond sort of
the PT Barnum pitches which I love doing
myself anyway and and and all of it is
to say that everything I'm working on
sort of centers on the same ideas and
approaches them from different kind of
prismatic angles but it's stuff I'm
really worried about for my kids and for
the future
it's it really is this idea that the
more sort of self-centered we get over
time the more isolated we get the more
difficult it's going to be to solve
these kind of big systemic problems and
there's this constant pull and
temptation on everything on an
individual level from social media to
the way we consume entertainment to the
way we insulate ourselves with beliefs
and views politically that sort of just
support our own - you know you see these
giant tectonic movements in a global
scale with countries are treating from
each other there's a sense of I just
need to worry about me I'm gonna consume
sort of what I want as opposed to kind
of a sense of smallness and collectivism
and humility and so every book I'm
working on sort of approaches that theme
differently you know Justice League does
and last night is very much about people
falling for that you know that that sort
of pitch from Lex Luthor so Batman II
laughs is almost the darkest culmination
an extreme version of that thinking the
Batman laughs as a character is Bruce's
worst nightmare you know he comes from a
place called the Dark multiverse and it
imagines that all of our hopes and fears
exist in this place and he's Bruce's
fear that one day he'll cross the line
kill the Joker in the Joker's heart will
contain a toxin that makes whoever kills
him the next Joker right so it's Batman
completely devoid of morals enough
and he's the Batman who always wins his
whole goal is just to win he's sort of
the apex predator of his world he's
destroyed world after world in this dark
realm and now he comes here to face off
with Batman and so his deep belief is
that Batman the bat is the only mammal
that can fly right and he believes that
the bats job is to show people how to
become the thing they were always meant
to become and soar and that is this
belief that evil and selfishness is
something that isn't found in the
natural world except in humans and it's
what makes us special so he thinks
that's what we're meant to be we're
designed to be dark we're designed to be
cruel and designed to be self-interested
so lean into that like I'll show you how
to be that you know win just win and so
that book is is deeply personal to me
and also extremely fun from a very very
sort of evil dark angle
I love the lettering I love the use of
that inside text text and I and I love
the perspective because it's a Batman
story that's never been told for those
very unique lens but we've also got
things like like the Batman himself I
wonder for you since you've written him
so much it's not a coincidence to me
that Heath Ledger's Joker was the first
mainstream Oscar and now with this black
label arc of the films we're looking at
a circuit basically run for the Joker
it's not at Comic Con because it's
theoretically going on a film circuit
what do you think makes Batman so
universally approachable that he's
breaking the barriers of these
comic-book norms oh I think I mean I
think at heart he's a really simple
folktale I mean Batman is enduring to me
because he says you take any trauma
anything bad in your life and you use it
as fuel to do good you know you make
your life matter our version of Batman
is very much about saying you win this
Batman wins when you recognize that
everything you do mean something
every day every moment do something that
makes the world better Joker is the
opposite to us Joker is the one that
says you win when you finally realize
that nothing you do matters and you just
embrace the insanity of thinking so and
the absurdity of that and Batman you
laugh is just like when he doesn't care
so that's why they make a really good
triangle but I think that's what makes
you know that for me that's what makes
him so adaptable and flexible and 80
years of seeing him everywhere from
space you know the deep-sea fighting
sharks to Gotham City yeah it's just
he's a really incredibly compelling
construction that just says
when something bad happens you take it
you use it as fuel to do something good
now all my shows Collider heroes and
comic-book shopping I talk about court
of owls so I would I would hate myself I
don't bring out that that masterpiece I
love that it falls in between a year one
and where we know the bat today and you
found the perfect way to kind of plant a
legacy and build a mythology within the
mythos without messing up continuity
where did that idea come from to go like
heater that's that's worked for me arc
after arc you know at least in terms of
my satisfaction with the work that we've
done not that it's perfect but just that
I've always tried to approach it as if
you only have one chance to write Batman
its this arc so what is the story you
need to tell right now and so each one
of the arcs that I did on Batman is
still to this day with metal and Batman
who laughs there about things that I
worry about for my kids so that I'm
hopeful about for myself or something on
my mind and court of owls really I wrote
it or thought of it at a time in my life
when I felt really displaced I was
really uncomfortable suddenly writing
Bruce Wayne at number one you know I
never thought I'd climb any ladder that
fast I never wanted to I was going back
to the city a lot to go into the office
to get help and in the office the DC
offices back when they were in New York
City were not far from where I grew up
so I would go from there back to the
neighborhood I grew up in and it was so
changed and nobody I knew lived there
anymore and there was this very humbling
sense of how the city you know or you
think you know changes right under your
feet and I knew that that was what I
wanted to do a story about Batman takes
all of his confidence from knowing
Gotham better than anybody else but what
if Gotham says you might know me right
now but you don't know me five years ago
ten years ago five years from now I'll
be a stranger to you yeah and there's
something deeply I think unsettling and
humbling and also important about that
so I was like if I can weaponize its
history and hide you know hide villains
he didn't know about in this long sort
of all the nooks and crannies that way
would be that and I was like what's the
natural enemy of a bat it's not really a
clown even though we all think it's know
so it was it was built from there it was
all from this this feeling honestly of
you know going home and suddenly seeing
it as this very strange place
ya know well I love that your Batman
comes from a psychological place a lot
of writers write for action or for
comedy and I always loved that you're
Batman
from and even just talking you now this
this psychological foundation that
really you feel it in the books and all
of these choices of resonate with me now
when do these next to come out when do
we get the last oh yeah it's a big month
for me yeah Batman who laughed seven the
big finale comes out on the 31st and so
does Batman last night on earth book two
amazing so yeah it'll be a big Batman
day for us and the Batman who laughs
actually in addition to just being the
finale of our series hooks into some of
the other stuff we're doing with year of
the villain it has a bit of a it's a
complete thing you can finish it and put
it down and it's over but there's a
surprise at the end like a coda like a
stinger that leads you forward into some
of the other stuff we're doing at TC
this year amazing I'm so excited to see
it I'm excited for the year of the
villain I'm excited for all this stuff
that's kind of up thank you so much guys
tune in for more